suite de notre série autour de l'ukraine
isabelle et zélie no2 tourangelle
témoins sont toujours à l'ouest du pays
à lviv là bas la vie se réorganise pour
s'adapter à l'évolution du conflit
l'objectif c'est d'éviter les trous dans
la raquette au niveau de la réception
des dons pour qu'il bénéficie à ceux qui
ont le plus besoin l'épisode 4 de ce
périple si particulier c'est avec
michael texier
c'est une ville sur le qui-vive que
découvre peu à peu isabelle et sa fille
et lié à chaque entrée d'immeuble des
habitants font le guet à l'intérieur les
consignes sont claires toutes les règles
en cas d'attaqué en cada larmes ce qui a
régulièrement des à l'âme où tout le
monde doit se réfugier dans le sous-sol
debian et il y en a qui les accueillent
ont hébergé des réfugiés en partance
pour la biélorussie le couple a décidé
de rester car ils peuvent être utiles
faire le lien avec les réfugiés de l'est
rassembler des informations travailler
pour que le pays ne tombe pas distille
ils se sont séparés de leurs enfants mis
à l'abri en suisse
une détermination qui a ému les deux
tourangelle tout comme la solidarité qui
s'organise toujours suis damian qui nous
emmène dans un endroit où ils collectent
les deux et on va pouvoir
à l'étrier pour les envoyer ensuite
aujourd'hui un tourangeau de veigné est
arrivé avec son camion rempli de dons
on va passer la journée à traîner des
médicaments c'est hyper important donc
on met ensemble les antidouleurs les
compresses enfin ses partisans tireur et
compresse on se rend compte du monceau
de choses à faire et surtout qu'en fait
c'est un travail de fourmi et que
effectivement aujourd'hui on va faire
tête je suis pas 50 boîtes mais que ce
sera toujours sept faits est toujours ça
de gagné
images marquantes enfin pour les deux
femmes ces grands panneaux le long des
routes qui reprennent les derniers mots
des treize soldats ukrainien morts sur
l'île aux serpents bombarder les russes
allez vous faire